[Laughter]
oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my days bro that dance
jesus christ
all right man um guys what's good people
welcome to the valentine's day special
edition
um yeah man i'm here for it
as you can see sorry to cut you off dude
as you can see we're both wearing the
send news hoodies
um hope you guys are loving the new
merch for this month you've got
two weeks left to cop it so yeah ma'am
you've got to send nudes and we've got
the heartbreak lolly
make sure you guys jump on that yeah man
enjoy that and uh
yeah man obviously patreon
do us a solid v day show some love
please
please i'm tired of asking i'm begging
you now please
you want to see me beg fine i'll beg
please run me the p
please man yeah g uh we need that uh we
love that
and um the content's juicy yeah we just
uh wrapped up recording the
valentine's special for patreon so jump
on and enjoy that
and uh guys i hope you're having a
beautiful monday yeah um
i hope valentine's went swimmingly for
you and if it didn't
hey man did you get the nudes did you
did you did you fap did you watch porn
like
whatever you needed to do to enjoy your
video i hope you went above and beyond
man yeah mom
um but yeah without further ado big man
um before i get into the fun fact guys
please like
comment subscribe just do do the most to
get us
to get the algorithm working for us man
we want what let's go for
300 likes 300 likes let's go 300 likes
start off start for start flight let's
go offline 300 likes that's that's easy
for you guys man
make sure you like comment subscribe and
yeah man before we get into it
um i'm gonna do a fun fact about
valentine's day so
um the tradition of giving flout of
valentine's day flowers dates back to
the 17th century
so giving red roses may be an obvious
romantic gesture today
but it wasn't until the 17th century
that giving flowers became
popular custom in fact the practice can
be traced back to
when king's child the kings charles ii
of sweden
learned the language of flowers which
pairs different flowers with specific
meanings
on a trip to persia and subsequently
introduced
in the tradition to europe the act of
giving flowers then became popular
during the sorry the act of giving
flowers then became a popular trend
during the victorian era including on
valentine's day
and where red roses symbolize deep love
so yeah date back to 17th century king
charles ii
of sweden you are the reason why people
spend so much money
swear down boy people spend pee on v-day
on flowers pee flower socks
flowers are expensive uk's are our teeth
bouquet is our teeth expensive ladies
love flowers ladies they do what is it
about them
they love i don't know because no one
could run me a flower and say
here you go thank you can say thank you
thank you for being you with flowers i
hate flowers they're an inconvenience
brother
uh people when they die in the vas and
you have to get rid of them you have to
find a virus
you need to get him in the bars and then
the dying device you have to get rid of
him above and then you've just got an
empty vase you have to get more
oh come on man i don't know man yeah as
a gesture it's going
and um what was i watching watching the
office the other day you see the office
um the american office yeah where um
this is one of the early seasons maybe
season one or two okay where
phyllis is getting flowers from pam is
vexed
ham livid livid yeah
is didn't get nothing pam will be fine
that would be calm
but all of a sudden because phyllis is
getting all the flowers pam's vex is
getting nothing
pisses me off pisses it's always it's a
competition in there i guess
in that kind of always a sense of
competition there's always a sense of it
it's dead ah i don't know mom i don't
know
here's what it is here's what is bro so
um
yeah man um so today guys we're gonna
revisit
the the best friend quiz yeah mom
last time i fumbled i
fumbled it last time but this time i'm
coming i'm ready i have no idea what the
[ __ ] questions are gonna be
but i'm ready i'm gonna try my best um
get my mind right uh let me bang some
alpha brain actually
i actually might take a shameless
shameless plug um for the on it alpha
brain
uh because i think when i took it last
time i didn't kick in on an episode i
think kicked in the episode after
oh that makes is it sense tutting
yeah it's always been a two-tailed i
have to remember yeah i mean on it if
you want to
sponsor the show you're more than
welcome it's fine
if you if you don't then [ __ ] off now
don't drop it
i don't know what you did oh my gosh
i don't know it's gone either yeah
[Laughter]
all right come so um
do you have all the questions i've got i
know i'm going to think of you go first
again
i know i'm going to get more questions
when you go through don't don't hide
don't hide the
cypher obviously you know i i adopted
the
the questions last time so i'm very
confident i'm very confident this round
all right who do you think is going to
win me or james yeah yeah
yeah write in the comments below cool
so let me see i've got
how many have i got one i only said 10
but i think i managed 10.
oh wait no nine i've got nine
all right so we'll have to imagine that
if i think of one more then i'll bang
out yeah
right so cool how first one how many
girlfriends like actual girlfriends have
you had
have i had since i met you i was gonna
ask you that question
really yeah but i didn't write enough i
was literally gonna ask that question
since you've met me so one
two are we including like that actual
proper girlfriend people that i would
call my girlfriend i say no more
i just have to make that's clarify yeah
yeah yeah yeah
no sightings than that just girlfriends
[Laughter]
um one two
three four gang four yeah four four four
four well done
um second one so you got that one right
hang on let me mark it
let's get
i was actually gonna ask you that
question good thing i didn't write down
okay
cool right so in my most broke time in
life
yeah what meal did i have every single
day oh that's that's easy tuna pasta
wrong no chicken pasta you said tuna you
said it
you waste man good that's what you get
that's physically what you might know
i'm right you might know i got the point
chicken
you said tuna with chest chicken pasta
incorrect you know we spoke about this
on the pod as well i remember
that's annoying cool that's so annoying
sorry um
cool what's the name apart from shits
and gigs what's the name of
my favorite podcast to listen to i knew
you can ask me that question fire in the
kid
how did you know i was gonna ask you i
just knew it i knew you guys would like
you [ __ ]
well done i didn't know why i just
thought you weren't gonna get it
you talk about it all the time i know i
talk about that's the thing i know i
talk about it all the time
but it's one of those things because you
don't watch it yeah you think it just
passes by
no i know you know what i'm talking
about but i didn't know you'd know the
name
okay do you know what i mean um cool
what's my favorite type of takeout
um
i don't think you've ever well you must
have told me i would probably go off the
bat the first thing that came to my head
is chinese
yeah it's chinese well done
what's that three for four three out
four yeah yeah yeah for four but hey
you'll get this one what's my biggest
pet peeve about you
i'm just going to say the first thing
that came to mind okay about me being
tired before we go out
tiredness yep
tiredness just tiredness yeah period
ah just tired is that hilarious um
come what's my biggest turn off during a
talking stage for a girl
um off the cuff
biggest turn off during talking stages
with a girl
off the cuff when they when they make it
bait that you can [ __ ] him
no nope
incorrect oh calling me out the blue
don't ever call me don't ever call me
[Laughter]
don't call me okay
that didn't come to mind because the
first thing that came to mind was that
because i know
you say you like the chase and stuff so
i like the chase a little bit but yeah
if uh now to be fair nah too fair like
if i if
if if i'm in the talking stage already
with you
and you've made it better i could [ __ ]
you that's probably good i mean
you may not make it to wife stage at
that point but
um you'll probably get the pipe um okay
so it wouldn't turn me off but yeah
calling me i'm not i'm not [ __ ] you
i'm not talking to you
call me the next day your number's
blocked
[Music]
i remember there was a girl years ago
on tinder from my short little stint on
tinder yeah
we were talking talking talking randomly
she i'm not randomly but she asked for
my number gave her a number
we talking what's that for maybe like
two days yeah um
we'd agreed to meet up i knew i wasn't
gonna meet her yeah but i
just so for full disclosure everyone
knows i'm socially awkward so when
someone says to me oh should we meet up
for a drink
i used to feel bad and be like yeah okay
i just say yes to everyone yeah and then
when day would come i love the time when
i agreed to do it
i would think yeah i'll do it because
the girl was paying so i thought i'm
gonna do it
and then um i think we had agreed to
meet up the next week
on the saturday night about one o'clock
in the morning i remember i was watching
anime on my laptop my phone's buzzing
look down see this girl's name i was
thinking from
hung up blocked
don't ever to say what you didn't even
let her ring out you
you existed extinct blocked
that's savvy because she lived far as
well oh if she lived local yeah she
might be thinking i might because i knew
she was drunk the fact you're ringing me
at 1am on a saturday i already know
you're drunk yeah
so i was thinking even if she's calling
for a pipe
yeah fossil she's never met me yeah
we've only spoken like twice
yeah yeah um so first of all that's a
bit weird yeah secondly
you live fast even if you are calling
for a pipe i'm not linking you i want to
talk to him i'm not leaving my house
yeah
um and thirdly
if you're not calling for a pipe what
are you calling what the [ __ ] are you
calling him
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] are you calling
for so hung up blocked it g
wow loved it wow you've never told me
that no no
i've already forgot about the very next
day that's probably why fair enough
oh cool this one
same quest this was actually in the last
quiz and i want to see if you know it
now
your brother's brother sisters
there's people in the people in the
audience now screaming screaming
screaming the name
there's people that know our trivia
better than we do it ourselves i know
i'm so happy i put this question in oh
my god can i get a clue or no
no your clue was the last quiz big man
i should have done my homework i told
you the answer then
oh oh
all right we'll circle back we'll circle
back i'm not answering it yet we'll go
back to that question
cool jesus that's annoying um
what actually no no we're not cycling
back jesus i can't even get right or
you're wrong
okay okay okay you have to give me a bit
of time not a bit of time but i think
um um
i'm never gonna get it um
[ __ ]
i just told you i'm never gonna get alex
and sophia i was never getting it
that's cool i was navigating fine it's
fine
i know i know where we stand and that's
that's fine
sometimes it's just good to know i was
never getting
um jesus this is interesting one
what was can you if you can remember
what was out mine and yours
most desperate cash grab during uni
um cool go you've got it already butler
in the buff oh i knew you were gonna say
that nope
more desperate than butler's in the buff
i knew you're gonna say that
more desperate in uni yeah i've
obviously got i mean anything is me and
you as well it was just me and you it
was just me and you i knew you were
gonna go brothers in the buff so you got
it wrong but you can guess again
um was it pre or post butlers
i wanna say pre i don't remember that
many jobs i did
cause i remember did blue ink we did
butlers
this one i am so happy that you forgot
it because it's
such an well it is an amazing story in
theory not really much happened
but it was the most desperate cash grab
we've ever done
and it's quite relevant in um relevant
in these times that we live in now
i have no idea tell me so for those who
don't know
and foodhead you can't remember back in
the day there was a time
when me and fuhad drove about three
hours
to cambridge so that we could
find out if we were eligible we gave a
blood test
to find out if we would be eligible
to be guinea pigs for a vaccine
oh my god they would give us this
disease and keep us locked up
in a room oh my god for two weeks that
was a long time i would never get that i
was never getting that
that that's not even in my memory
um yeah they look they were gonna lock
us up for two weeks
and after the two weeks we'd get like 5k
i remember now you're saying i remember
it i was never going to get any fainted
in the blood test
they took so much blood i remember i had
to be funny enough i actually remembered
the top i was wearing now that you've
said it i remember the top i was wearing
it's
so weird i was wearing the you know back
in the day the um top man uh
mickey mouse like sweatshirts yes
wearing that
i don't know why that came to mind but i
know i was wearing that mad as if you
know that i don't know why
mm-hmm i remember lifting it up and she
was taking blood out my um
yeah we drove all the way down to
cambridge for that i didn't even know it
wasn't i had no money
i we had to stop off at my mom's yard to
grab 20 pounds so i could get petrol did
we
we did i don't remember this g we did we
did
because you were the driver it brings a
bit you might remember this bit
my i couldn't afford to get my car
cleaned okay
my windscreen was filthy and i had a
bottle of water
and i was driving and i tried to pour
the water on the windscreen
and it flew back to my face
[Laughter]
and i think we bought a mcdonald's on
the way back in change because i had a
bag of change
a sandwich bag of copper spam and we sat
and got all the coppers together and got
like
maybe one more meal to share
we were [ __ ] broke it could never
have been to share
it could never have been to share i must
have heard like a couple quid somewhere
it can never have been to share imagine
breaking off a happy meal
it could never have been we were poor it
could never have been we were so
poor um but yeah it turns out it didn't
work out um we had too many antibodies
in our blood already
they needed people who had never been
sick um
but yeah last question that i've got
geez that's annoying
so what's that so so far you've got
one two three four out of
eight and this is question number nine
so
after a one night stand a girl left
um my hotel without an essential
item of clothing what was the item of
having
her shoes gang well done i remember
exactly
people are probably thinking how the
[ __ ] do you forget your shoes clam
i didn't even think she forgot them no
she didn't forget them so basically this
is the thing um me
and all the fellas were away um i sat
with a girl
and the next morning we must have slept
in or something
because all you man came in the bedroom
you men were ready to go
everyone was dressed and ready to go we
were on holiday everyone was dressed and
ready to go
the girl got the girl was naked i
remember
she had she had the covers here she was
like james
james i was like yo i don't know what
you want me to do
they're already in now they're already
in so she scattered into the bathroom
got a dress on
she couldn't find her shoes and you men
were trying to boogie you might want to
get out and about and you were like
let's go home come on let's go
and she was so nervous that she just
left the hotel without her shoes
i didn't see those shoes again i didn't
that's the thing that
it's just like but how how do you just
walk out like that
how it was a walk she had a walk
that's bad i would have found it i don't
care i don't care
if i was here i would have found it i've
got no choice she was she must be mortal
oh
god oh god i don't think i've ever done
have i ever done a like a proper
i was gonna say i've ever done a proper
walk of shame but it's the day you
picked me up
wearing the pink fan you're talking
about this van
i can't describe it you look like the
[ __ ]
i just wish that i had like a like
when in cheetahs do you remember and she
is there's a show
ah humana two years but so much of our
audience is young there's a show that
used to be on whatever channel it was
the most random channel ever
called cheetahs where this guy would
just go out and catch
infidelity fam and there'd always be
pictures from the private investigator
and there's always like one picture of
him opening the door one picture
looking this way that way one picture
and closing the door
i found when i picked you up that was
you oh i said i'm outside i just just
came out
and you just walked into the car and my
pink top yeah fam
oh that was funny god that was so funny
that's probably that's
embarrassing but yeah that's all my
questions i've got nine questions um i
actually added two more since we spoke
because since he's working actually
okay cool boom so if you how many of you
got nine as well i've got eight now i'll
probably think of another one all right
cool
and one of the questions is one of the
ones you've asked me so hopefully you
remember so what did you get five out of
nine
i don't know you tell me hang on yeah i
think so
let's have a look see one two three four
five
five out of nine that's poor that's poor
from me
it would have been six because i [ __ ]
said tuna pasta i'm an effects
let us know what you guys got in the
comments as well if you guys are playing
along um
cool first question yeah what have i
always said is my biggest fear
what have you always said is your
biggest thing and i've said it on the
pod for sure
i think i said it on a episode with
either bellarin or jacob
yeah um cool i'm you [ __ ] up by
telling me that detail
because not necessarily [ __ ] up but um
i was thinking
is he is he talking about like the
biggest fear that he said this is my
biggest fear
or what is something that strikes the
most fear into him
which are kind of two different things
yeah very true um your biggest fear
is [ __ ] um
you have said this it was the bella
right by the way and
i already can't remember what it was i
know what it's about
okay tell me what it's about then so
it's about um so it was the bella rep
and we were talking about um i spoke
about
my biggest fear is like being alone
um or no but not being able to support
myself
i think that's what i said my biggest
fear is and you said
yours was something around the lines of
not being able to support your family
some it was something financial and
there was something along the lines not
being able to support your family
but it was
i'm just going to go out and win and say
this isn't it but i'm just going to have
to say
biggest fear is yeah not been able to
support your family
i might give you that because it's not
being able to provide for my future kids
oh okay so
what do you guys think should i let him
have it
semantics okay um this next one should
be an easy one
what subway did we always get in uni oh
tuesday meatball marinara fam okay
you man don't know me meeple marinara we
banged that every tuesday in uni
barbecue and sweet onion come on man
come on
you rem and chloe wasn't it yeah chloe
yeah oh my days what time
what a time so that's two um
so let me take these sorry yes yes
um what did i say was my favorite movie
jesus christ your favorite movie ever
we got asked this
oh on drew's pod did we get asked it
don't look at me oh god
um [ __ ]
the bed what movie did you say i said
whiplash
oh great movie yeah i completely forgot
you said that i would not have got that
if you ask me that question
uh you said
[ __ ] you know i have no idea you said
uh i'm gonna punch something when you
tell me because i'm gonna know
oh can you tell me a genre or no no what
i asked you for your sister's
your brother's i told you that yeah i
know i know
um i don't know shawshank redemption
i wouldn't have got it even if you told
me genre i still want to go right
but i do remember you saying that
because i literally
said afterwards oh no i am db number one
right movie all the time
um okay so you're two out of three all
right cool
what's my favorite starter at my
favorite restaurant
uh shiitake bao at tattoo yeah gang gang
guys there you go if your man don't know
about if you manny lot if you men don't
know i don't even just manny i think
there's one in edinburgh and lee's i
think
you know about that there's one oh yeah
there's a shitakey bao
ah oh it's the great the greatest
starter you ever have tattoo
is it's different it's a legit
restaurant different gravy
anyway number five
what song was i dancing to you that was
recorded on night out that you always
laugh at
return on the mac
oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my gosh that dance
jesus christ so for context there was a
night out that we went out years uh
how many years ago four years four maybe
three four yeah yeah probably four
probably four um and it was a night of
nights
and we're at the end of our tether at
this point yeah we're in this club who
had
wearing like a ready pinky t-shirt
with a leather jacket over the top and
someone spilt a drink on him
so he's he's got drink all down his top
he's sweating to bits the jackets around
his elbows
and he's just frontal whining to return
to the mac
and he's mouthing all the words it's the
funniest thing it's in my snapchat
history
funniest video of all time highest
bidder gets it oh
god that's jokes
do you hear me privately hi there gets
it oh my days we'll split the props hey
miner
uh okay cool so you're what you're
four four
sorry go on you're four for five [ __ ]
you know you're doing you're doing
better than last time
all right this should be easy how long
have i lived in money it's not easy
i'm not good at years i know that's why
i'm not because i thought to me it would
be easy
oh god that's not easy i know your
terrible with yours
you've lived in manny oh i can work it
out hang on
this is your fifth year
is it you had your first house for one
year
your second house with ryan for the
second year you lived with bella in the
last house for two years
and this is your fifth year but how long
have i lived in money so i've lived in
money for five years
that's what you're saying it's your
answer oh god
don't do this i'm asking a question
don't do this
let's get a question
uh don't don't try and get the calendar
i'm not getting the calendar out
hang on
i'm trying to think when you moved here
um
i bet you are shut up
um
four years gang well done i just
remembered you man didn't finish your
second year at least
at the last spot well done gang four
years yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah january 2017 like the 20th of
january 2017
what was what was my first slash only
car
like the make model peugeot 307 easy
nuts in the back seat nuts in the
backseat
[Laughter]
well that's mine doing up expose you
left nuts in that backseat
calm you're flying through this you're
six out of seven you know
fam i told you i'm a true friend i told
you you've done well
you've done well i'm not gonna lie to
you you've done well thank [ __ ] you've
done what you redeemed yourself
thank [ __ ] all right before i ask you
this question i have to think actually
because
i just wrote these questions actually no
i'm just asking i'll probably think at
the time so same question you asked me
how many girlfriends have i had since
you've met me
well since you've known me that you'd
called you told me this is my girlfriend
yes and i'm going to count them in my
head now because i have nothing
okay cool okay
i feel like there's going to be one or
two that you argue with me about
right i probably already know the one or
two you're thinking of
actual cool like actual girlfriend
cool because there's one in my head i
already know the one you're thinking of
that what what are you going to say
there's one you heard that one that i'm
i
you told me she's your girlfriend but i
feel like
if if we speak about it you were dating
do you know what i mean i know i know
exactly who you mean really i know
exactly i think i know exactly what you
mean okay cool
um but lim i'm gonna include her anyway
so we'll see
that's your problem all right cool then
i won't include that's your problem [ __ ]
you
right oh hang on
wait [ __ ] do i even remember
yeah i think six
excuse me six
six that's wrong that's definitely wrong
i know that's wrong i know that's wrong
it's definitely not six
let me count them here that's that's
wrong okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
well right the names on your phone and
then show me or
no not the names i can say without
people picking up on who
it is okay so
your first girlfriend lester
you didn't include her did you you
didn't include that did you get yourself
six but go on go on first girlfriend
yeah uh i forgot about that j mims
yeah um
jolo yeah
the girl you don't for jollo
okay but i know i know what you mean but
is that the one you were thinking of no
okay i know who the other one is no
mates
yes for sure and then
the one before no mates the one that
dumped you
i know you're talking about okay
the fact that you said she dumped you
has to count as a girlfriend
okay okay that's six that is six so well
done but
i wouldn't count the one you're done for
jolo
yeah i knew you were going to say that
because i don't think i ever
said did i ever say future's my goal i
don't think i did
i don't think i did you did because
you had agreed because i remember having
a conversation with you
that you made her your girl literally
a few days before you dumped her that
was what the whole beef was about
a few it was literally a matter of days
from when she became your girlfriend to
when you dumped her
it was days and that's what the whole
hubbub was and that's why she called you
a fuckboy
because if you just stopped seeing her
there would have been no beef
we have to talk about this off-camera
because there's stuff i want to say but
it's not 40s man you know
all right man if i'm wrong i'm wrong not
to be fair
it it patterns up because i wasn't even
i was looking at names that i couldn't
even remember
some of them so yeah yeah and me all
right that's very peak of me but i'll
give you that i'll give you the six
i'll give you six all right i'll give
you something i'll give you six
six fair enough fair enough fair enough
fair enough so unfortunately
guys i lost this round i only had eight
questions
you got seven right um but yeah if you
guys knew the answers to some of them
let us know in the comments as well
cool man um no that's that that's out
the way thank [ __ ]
um we'll keep recording i just
remembered i forgot something so hang on
one second
i'll be right back i'm gonna charge
um
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
for those for those who don't know um
it's my birthday in
two days my birthday is on wednesday
james just got me a
a birthday cake yeah man ah
so happy birthday fam the big 30 30 you
know 30 years of age from 30.
outing wow this is a nice cake thank you
so much you're very welcome gee thank
you so much blow that candle and wish us
wealth please
we need it wish us all the wealth
oh my hey
do you want to know this is um thank you
for that by the way my energy um
this is i'm gonna do a fun fact in the
middle of the show as opposed to
in the beginning because we did one um
you know they're happy birthday too
blah blah blah the fun fact about that i
wrote it down so it was um
it was like coin doll written by
two sisters uh let me find it hold on
hold on hold on hold on
because there's one there was one i was
going to say so patty hill and mildred
hill
um co-wrote happy birthday to you it was
originally
good morning to you because it was a
melody they just copied the same melody
they were primary school teachers or one
of them was a primary school teacher and
she would sing
good morning to you to the kids and then
they
changed it to happy i don't know how and
why but they changed it to happy
birthday to you
and that's how we patted and this was in
like the early 90s like 1902 or
something like that
then i was so paid um but the thing is
i've read more into it
they it wasn't um what's the word i'm
looking for it wasn't like patented like
copyright it wasn't right
it wasn't copywritten trademarked or
whatever yeah until like
later and i think even until after they
died or something that makes sense yeah
so
yeah [ __ ] patty hiller and mildred hill
google it if you guys want to read more
about that what the [ __ ] did they do for
people's birthday before
no i do nothing no idea nothing no idea
but i found that very interesting stuff
that's interesting i wanted to meet up
on it so it's connected
but yeah man thank you for that bro i
was nice to that i was thinking where
are you going
i was thinking where you going manta
keep recording where are you going man
got me a birthday cake nah thank you mom
you're welcome gee thank you much enjoy
if you guys are saying happy birthday in
the cameras or lovely yeah drop in the
comments man yeah yeah
thank you so much guys dirty man 30.
synthwave some skin
yeah send them some skin man
fellas too don't hold back don't be shy
man
um but yeah so that's all done that's
all good to go
so um guys as you know um
i specifically asked in the last pod
for video clips for today so we could
have some fun interact yeah get jiggy um
patrons it was on you you fumbled the
bag
we added a benefit specifically for you
to get involved with the show
and you didn't run about it and that's
that's literally fine i can't force you
to do something you don't want to do
and that's fine so obviously [ __ ] off
[Laughter]
now i'm playing but um that's all good
but today's
uh was worse valentine's or best or
worse valentine's experience
um but we have got one we have got one
that we want to read out
um from someone on patreon so
it wasn't a video but um it's a lovely
little uh
conversational topic so
but first i've always been funky about
valentine's i've always been um
i've never really wanted to make a big
deal out of valentine's day not
necessarily not wanting to make a big
deal out of it
but in terms of like gifts and stuff
like that i've always found it like
tricky like not necessarily but i've had
like arguments with girlfriends in the
past like for example if i have to work
on valentine's day or something like
that
and then oh it's valentine's day yeah
and i'm like yeah but like
valentine's day can be whatever day you
make it yeah do you know what i mean of
course it can be whenever yeah as long
as you're celebrating yeah as long as
you're just trying to
express how much you love someone then
we can make valentine's day whatever we
want to make it
they weren't having it they've never
been having it my my issue with
not necessarily issue with valentine's
day but because my birthday's three days
after valentine's day yeah
i always tend to take a week off for my
birthday anyway
and yeah it always tends to fall around
just before just before valentine's day
and obviously after my birthday so i
didn't
take off like for example this week i
would have taken off
monday to monday um and i'm meant to be
in dubai today
you know i was meant to be in dubai
today but um that got canceled blah blah
but yeah so i always take that off for
my birthday
and for the past few years i've just not
done anything
yeah yeah yeah it's not really been and
last year we were in
amsterdam in on valentine's day i
believe we were on that i believe we're
in amsterdam
yeah yeah yeah yeah for my birthday
exactly because i always take a week off
so yeah yeah yeah it patterns out so
there you go i don't really do much
on that day i've never really had i
think
prior when i lived in london things i
can't remember
i can't remember what i did but i know
i'd never really had like a [ __ ]
experience to my knowledge
because it would have stuck out yeah but
i think all the other days have just
been calm like all the other valentine's
days have just been calm i've never
really had a [ __ ] experience like i've
not had [ __ ] experiences
but i've had like stressful situations
like well i remember one time
with a girlfriend at the time said uni
she wanted obviously we
used to see each other like every
weekend so it's obviously long distance
things yeah you know who it is yeah yeah
and we see each other every week
or every weekend anyway but obviously
for valentine's day
she wanted me to see her and every
weekend we'll go out to a restaurant
and stuff anyway but she want me to see
her so i had to i wasn't driving
at this time uh well obviously i was
driving but i didn't have my car
um and i had to get the coach
from coventry all the way to wherever we
went
uh normal kings we met or something to
go out for dinner and it was a stressful
trying to book a
table um and then like couldn't get a
table anywhere
search and search and search and search
and then obviously it's my fault that i
didn't book a table in advance
and then i've got to get on a long ass
coach journey um
down to luton to go out to this
restaurant and then we go out to the
restaurant and then the whole
and then we'll go back and [ __ ] and
whatever and then i've got to get on the
coach the next morning all the way back
to uni and it's just like that's no
different to any weekend
yeah it's no different we could have
just postponed this day until until
friday or something like
why did we have to do this um
but i remember there was one uh
this is with the same girlfriend
actually there was one
i don't think you know what i'm going to
say okay sorry my bad i hope you don't
know what i'm going to say okay
you no you don't know what i'm okay okay
okay okay so
let me paint the picture i love it story
time story time
let me paint the picture yeah so
valentine's day yeah i'm thinking i'm
trying to do it up this is early so i
must have been like
19 at this point early early this is
probably my first
valentine's day so
obviously your boy hadn't been going gym
that much but i've been trying my best
yeah
yeah so i was i was lean but i didn't
have much mass
yeah lean didn't have much math yeah
so um i was on the shakes isn't it the
master i was on the mat shakes yeah yeah
into my shape yeah um so girlfriend
comes over
chin and chin in i got a teddy bear and
a card and whatever whatever
i'm thinking cool let's like uh like
this is
remember when trey like having sex to
trey songz was just the one
do you know what i mean yes you weren't
allowed to [ __ ] just straight oh and
funny dropper was in the back
oh my god you weren't allowed to have
flex i remember sorry to cut you off i
remember begging a chick
this was in my first year of union you
know exactly
playlist that was about 47 minutes long
and i remember thinking
if i can make it through the whole thing
it's it's a wrap
i don't need to pay for dinner anymore
if i can make it through the whole
playlist
i'd get oh oh that's hilarious
i'll get about five tracks in and start
tingling come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on
you're not even up we still got 20
minutes let's go
um that's jokes so anyway
we're there and i'm thinking you know
what i'm this is my first like proper
valentine's day with girlfriend and
stuff
let me do this up yeah so she's
downstairs
in our uni house and i'm like cool
i run upstairs and i'm like i told her
i'm just going to toilet she's out there
run upstairs fam candles all up in the
in the room candles and i'm like yeah
yeah rose petals
because i bought some flowers so just
pick the rose petals yeah yeah yeah yeah
drink them on the bed and i'm like yeah
yeah yeah
yeah your boy stripped down to the
calvin's
baby oil everywhere they were everywhere
i'm glistening glistening and warm
family yeah and then i text her
like come upstairs she's like cool cool
come upstairs she open the door
your boys just
just ready to pounce my girl walks in
looks at me
and laughed
the shock of it she didn't know what she
was coming upstairs for
she opened the door saw candles and
you're boiled glistening in in the light
and she was like i'm sorry
i covered up you know
you get the duvet you're just there like
my skinny little arms and legs just what
what
crosstalk i know you would cut i know
one leg crossed the other
side what's
i made sure funny pump out the [ __ ]
you've never told me this i didn't tell
anyone
i didn't tell anyone oh every man was
downstairs
oh she was i'm sorry i'm sorry it's not
funny i was just like
no it's not because it was vice versa
i'm pouncing on it vice versa i'm
pounding on it
tray in the back i'm solid immediate i
can't help but wait
i would have left left
off fan she walked in and laughed oh
oh that will crush me fam that's what's
been good i need to hit jim
i need to just i need to have more of an
impact yeah do you know what i mean yeah
i'm she's looking at a boy i need to be
a man ah
that would crush myself because i was
thinking if tr himself was doing this
she's gassed true if trey was here yeah
she's gassed obviously gassed
but a little old jimmy nah oh she just
snotted
she snotted
humiliating but stress ah
it is what it is anyway let's read this
one
so from a lovely lady on patreon
um here we go so
so basically yeah she sent this one in
and she said
this is regards to this valentine's just
now just now yeah this one's uh
she's not from the uk um she's on about
this valentine's right now right
so i don't think she's from the uk from
the way this there's a message sound she
can't be in the uk
okay because these men are living free
that's all i know
she's living free okay okay i read a
restaurant
um right cool so been talking to the guy
for a few weeks
banter is great emotional intimacy sexy
time on the phone in the evening gang
gang that's what you say gang gang oh
gang gang i love that i love it when
they say
he invites me to spend uh this
valentine's weekend with him
i drive an hour get a hotel new dress
new hair the works invested a lot of
money on this
she put in brackets good job early 30s
all right love
calm down we get it we get it
um anyway so i was told about a uh
i was told about restaurant reservations
and was looking forward to connecting
with homeboy
none of that comes to pass this guy
spends
most of the time on snapchat or out and
about
in my car leaving me at the hotel
um also showing so little curiosity
curiosity in my life when we're together
i could have been in my hometown
hometown well i can't speak today
hometown hanging with the my girlfriends
but here i am
on my phone far from home not being
folded like a pretzel
oh she wanted to get
dirt yeah she wants to get room in fam
oh
she said granted i was getting folded on
the pretzel on the first night but
that's it
so not worth it i wish i could give a
yelp review
damn damn damn damn
and then she finished off with throwing
me under the bus and said reminds me
when james mentioned that he talks a lot
of crowd with a girl
and then in the moment it's wham bam
that's a joke they they love to slide it
in there
it was a joke it was for a bit of comedy
jest on the pod
and these men want to throw me under the
bus it's all good um but now
that's pete the bit that got for
me was the out and about in my car
so you went to see playboy and he said
i was going to say the bit that got me
initially was because she said she went
to link him right
mm-hmm but she got the hotel um she got
the
she got everything really that's that
threw me off the bat first and foremost
yeah yeah yeah yeah
she comes to visit me if someone's come
to visit me i'm sorting out well i'm
assuming he sorted out
the reservations because she said it
never came to pass
there so she said she said i was told
about reservations but it never came to
pass
so he said he booked restaurant things
didn't didn't
man said run me your keys quick
run me the car keys quick this [ __ ]
don't drive
run with the car keys quick and he's
just dilly dallying out in the whip
that's not his
snap
nah that's a vile she drove an hour for
this that's a violation oh 100
that's a violation valentine's that's a
violation
no one should do that to anyone no you
shouldn't have to go through that you
shouldn't have to if
if you just wanted to smash just say big
man come any other day
don't do this don't get fancy don't just
come through so we can have a nasty time
yeah that's it fam some people go
through the most just to smash
and it baffles me nah nah
he's he's definitely in the wrong for
that man hundred percent definitely in
the wrong
she should have piped up she should have
she should have punched her she
shouldn't make it so you want to change
that
she should have messaged if she would
have messaged him saying
big man you're out in my whip well i'm
when you could be here folding me like a
pretzel
oh my god the u-turn would have been
dangerous he could have lost his life
he would have peeled back fam he would
have been what am i doing
guys are idiots you know guys you can't
give us too much autonomy
we're idiots fam we don't know what's
on the table unless it's spelled out
unless it's folded up whatever this is
literally there
we don't know even though he smashed you
the night before
say he does know he doesn't know do you
know what i mean yeah the guys are thick
guys are thick until you message me big
money you know you you could be a follow
me like a pretzel
he wouldn't be like what am i doing he
would have peeled back
i would have loved to have been a flight
in the wall and seeing people oh 100 it
will make me 100
nah in her whip that's a vile man
that's when you know you're whack fam as
soon as man
asks for the keys she must have been
like what am i doing here
i would have said hell no i would have
got the keys and just gone
what do you mean man new dress new dress
new hair everything
everything she'd make herself look good
dolled up for me like a pretzel big man
that's
sexy big man that's sexy ah
that reminded me of uh remember when we
went to the sex show
in amsterdam this time last year and one
of the
one of the guys literally folded her
like a pretzel do you remember
do you remember you move he did yeah
yeah he did i don't even know
he got he crossed
yeah that's a literal pretzel yeah that
was like wow
that one was wild yeah yeah that texture
was a weird experience it was a weird
experience
i'm happy we did it and i can say i've
done yeah yeah yeah but it was a bit
like
oh they're they really they're really
big yeah yeah
they're really [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah wild
oh that's a violation yeah that's tough
that's tough i don't really know what to
suggest there's nothing to suggest you
can't link him again that's it yeah you
have to lock him up i can't drink him
again
you have to block his number it's done
especially because she has to drive out
of town to even link him
an hour an hour you can't that's the
thing he can't win that back now he
can't
he can't there's nothing he can do
unless he turns up too high oh yeah just
put balls up with
i don't even know i was gonna say
flowers and i was like come on
flowers on lube fam just said sorry
let's go i'm gonna
if that was me i'd roll up to her yard
with an actual pretzel yeah i was just
about
take a bite come take a bite
guards would fly off like jim carrey and
what's that movie called bruce almighty
this thing yeah fam guys rags oh
gums would fly off that's that's tough
man
that is man he's he's a prick for doing
that yeah he's a burden so that's a bad
that's a bad valentine's day sorry to
hear that sorry to hear that
um but yeah thank you for sharing
um and i think we i am uh the also
yeah let me see if i can
[Music]
master up
two seconds my geez
okay i just need to type it in
oh this is a bit long but why not
let's go cool am i the [ __ ] for
telling a friend of a friend
that i could link his girl and then
doing it on the same night
so that's just like the title it's like
okay background
when i was at uni i met this girl on a
night out she had the craziest body
jiggle back thick thighs great chest all
of that jesus
anyways we got on and had great convo
used to link almost every week he put in
brackets the sex was filthy as well
the sex was filthy as well unfortunately
i left uni in my second year for
personal reasons
but she kept in touch and i'd go back to
see her and chill every now and again
and we still talk on the phone and
message each other but it's been agents
since i last saw her
uh long story short pre
long story short pre the first lockdown
so i pre-locked down one
one of my closest boys invited me to a
house party
uh invited me to a house party he got an
invite from
a guy that he went to uni with um we got
to the door
and to my surprise said girl opens it
she immediately mounts me
wraps her legs around my waist and in
excitement kisses me on the cheek
i'm instantly gassed and my mind goes
straight back to
the to the debuggery that i used to get
up to when i was with her at uni
but she tells me that this party is her
boyfriend who happens to be the brother
that invited
his boy so later on during the night
um this boy gets in a drunken state and
starts getting a bit rowdy
and starts getting a bit too aggressive
towards me and my boy
i let it slide for the longest time but
as the night progresses things get worse
and the two of them started to get
physical obviously i jumped in the
middle
too he's going right sorry obviously
i've jumped in the middle
as my boy isn't really confrontational
isn't the confrontational type
and i'm bigger than both of these men
okay
sometimes people love to sometimes
people like that they're in it
oh it's not an ego thing just my next
great across the ground want to walk
yeah anyway um yeah you say it's a
bigger bro whatever
um in my slight rage i've shouted out at
next man
in quotations big man if this carries on
i'll leave with your girl
said girl i know i know fam i know
that's
bold said girl heard the commotion
downstairs
and and has dragged me out away and has
dragged me away to the garden
i told her that i was feeling about
leaving and she said she didn't want me
to she didn't want me to go
but if i was going to go that she would
walk with me so we dipped
and when she got back to mine she pushed
me to the bed and we started lips in
as you can imagine the nastiness soon
followed
or oh my think oh my think i'm
i don't know what that means all my
think i'm slightly addicted i'm assuming
you're saying all i'm thinking about is
that i'm slightly addicted
um for going through with it but i want
an outside opinion i might be also so
the top question again was
am i the answer for telling a friend of
a friend that i could link his goal
and then doing it the same night uh
do you wanna nah that's a long synopsis
so uh yeah
okay yeah so synonymous he got invited
to a party his brethren got invited to a
party and his bridge invited him to that
party yeah he gets to the party and
actually sees the go that he used to
smash
the smash who's going out with the guy
who's running the party yes cool
so during the night him and his boy
chill chill chilling
and donny whose party it is starts
getting a bit rowdy and a bit physical
with
his his brethren because he's the bigger
guy he jumps in the middle
and says yo stop stop stop and then
later on expresses to donny who's pie is
big man if
if your [ __ ] carries on i can link i
will link your girl in it
and then he leaves the girl walks him
home and then he [ __ ] the girl
basically cool um and he wants to know
if he's the [ __ ]
that's an interesting one um
right it's an interesting one
it goes back to the one you remember
when we said like
being an [ __ ] doesn't in and
sometimes in
am i the [ __ ] being an [ __ ]
doesn't define you
because it's like one of those ones
where it's like some people when we're
like am i the [ __ ] i'm like
yeah you're the [ __ ] when i'm saying
it i mean i'm and i'm also saying you're
a bad person yeah
i mean yeah yeah like you're not joking
you're not just an [ __ ] you're a bad
person yeah
but that doesn't always mean the case
when i say you are the [ __ ] you know
what i mean
it doesn't necessarily mean you're a bad
person because at the same time from why
you don't know this guy you owe this guy
nothing nothing i'm never
a huge fan of intentionally
bringing truth into scenarios unrelated
truths into scenarios do you know what i
mean
like for example like if mean this is
obviously hypothetical but like you say
it mean you're arguing
and i'm like yeah but your brother your
mom's gonna die of cancer to shut up
but your mom actually has cancer but
only i know that do you know what i mean
it's a bit like that has nothing to do
with this
yeah why are you doing that yeah i'm not
a fan of that yeah regardless if you
know the person or not yeah because
you're the only one you you and
potentially him and the girlfriend are
the only ones in this whole scenario
that are proving
to this information so that's a bit like
it's techie
it's a techie like you can there's ways
that you can chuck it without
having to get that specific yeah yeah
low and specific
so that's a bit of an [ __ ] move but
again like i said you don't owe this guy
anything yeah
so it's one of the ones was like for
that you're an [ __ ] because
uh you didn't need to do it but at the
same time it doesn't matter if you're an
[ __ ] because
you don't know this guy and clearly you
don't like this guy yeah so be an
[ __ ] all you want i don't care
like that doesn't make you a bad person
because you're you're an [ __ ] to
someone that you don't know and like
um but at this uh as far as [ __ ] the
girl that night
i don't care like i don't necessarily
think that's an [ __ ] thing because
she is the one that asked to come
through and
again you don't know the guy yeah you
don't owe him [ __ ] if you then went back
to him the next day and i was like oh
big man by the way i [ __ ] your girl
like that then you are an [ __ ] no
need
literally no need yeah um but yeah as
from
where i'm sitting um yeah uh also for
the first bit
not [ __ ] for the second bit but a bit
ass even though you are
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] i also think
it's um
going back to the point about say an
unrelated truth in a situation
i also think it's um
weird and kind of like a not necessarily
an ego maniac kind of thing but because
he also mentioned that he's bigger than
the both of them
yeah and he was like oh but i can also
[ __ ] your girl as well it's like
why what does that do for you yeah you
could have said that you'll knock him
out
but he already knows that so he further
needs to tell him something he doesn't
know see exactly that's that's egotistic
in my opinion yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's definitely that's weird um but i
don't necessarily think you're the
answer for
i think you're i think you're the
[ __ ] for saying oh big man i'm going
to take a girl if i leave as well that's
an awesome move i don't think you're an
[ __ ] for actually [ __ ] i think
she's more of the arsenal fighter oh
yeah she's just definitely the ass off
for [ __ ] you
because she won she didn't have to um
she didn't have to go with you she
didn't have to go with you she didn't
have to go in the yard in the yard she
didn't have to jump on you
obviously that's natural reaction she
was excited
as soon as that if that was me and i
opened the door and my ex
flame just jumped to me i'm [ __ ]
tonight that's the first time
whose party this is tonight that's the
first thing that's come to mind so
if i'm if i'm you in this scenario i can
understand why you did it
but i feel like the girl is more of an
answer than you are just in that [ __ ]
context but um
for you saying it to the guy i think
that's an [ __ ] move yeah she's
unknown
anyway do you think that she actually
jumped on man
wrapped a leg raps her legs kissed the
cheek when her man's in the yard
it's his birthday party it's his
birthday party
man's got the cake and all that singing
happy birthday if i saw that i needed an
explanation yesterday
on the spot who is that on the spot oh
that's a guy i used to [ __ ]
who invited him you're jumping on next
man he used to fight he's not your
brother is that what you're telling me
he's not your brother
because that's that's brother he has to
be your brother he can't be a guy you
used to [ __ ]
because this is my odd and this is my
birthday and you're my girl
so i'm not surprised he got physical
though i'm not surprised
that's why he's throwing his dick around
he was upset if i saw that in my
peripheral and it's my birthday it's my
gal
lochna have the locker i'm looking off
the pie what do you mean
i'm looking at the pot the whole shebang
is done the birthday's done she's done
the whole thing's done
i'm asking him straight how do you know
how would you know my gal or how do you
know my ex
how'd you know sharon i used to do a
thing of her me too
we've got something in common at least
yeah yeah yeah let's grab a drink slag
and then she went back and fought man
that same
what was her excuse when she wasn't in
the yard anymore
very valid question very valid question
because i'm assuming she would have been
staying at her boyfriend's yard fam it's
my birthday party what was it because
disturbing just cracked on she has no
respect
zero zero respect
c'est la vie man what can we do ah some
people move
wild you know yeah some people move wild
i was as i say like
the fact that she didn't care about the
consequences when she wrapped legs round
man
at the door she didn't care about what
the boyfriend was going to say about it
she don't rate the boyfriend whatsoever
she needs a man i feel like
that i'm very not very impartial with i
can understand
from ours perspective um that is a it's
a peak thing to do but
because of the fact that they've not
seen i'm assuming they've not seen each
other in a while and the first thing she
did when open door was seeing a guy that
she used to have filthy sex with
unbeknownst nat unbeknownst that she
didn't know that he was going to come to
the party as well
i can understand that kind of being a
natural reaction oh don't get me wrong i
can see it being a natural reaction
but there's there's there's limits i
know i know that's what i was going to
say like because of the fact that
there's a natural obviously i would have
if i would have expected maybe like a
hug kind of thing like oh my god
but the fact that she jumped on him
wrapped her legs and lips that there was
no
thought of oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] am i
doing yeah i mean yeah that's what i
thought of that
i'm trying to put it in my in my shoes
if i opened the door
saw a ting that i used to bang at my
girlfriend while i'm at my girlfriend's
house
first of all my initial reaction is not
to jump on anyone of course as a guy
i would have been like what are you
doing what are you doing
i'll close the door i'll close the door
so what are you doing here
are you doing it what
what the [ __ ] are you doing here i ain't
jumping on no one
i would look at i would look at the boy
and i actually got invited like
why didn't you tell me what is this
what's going on why didn't you tell me
that
well i don't know shut shut up the [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up
get the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up shut
the [ __ ] up what the [ __ ] is she doing
here big one what are you trying to do
i'll be rattling my girlfriend
you know what the [ __ ] i'll be rattled
i'll tell you you better shut the [ __ ]
up
i don't want to hear anything about your
[ __ ] mouth do you hear me do you hear
me
shut the [ __ ] up you don't know me
you've never met me you've never seen me
don't look at me don't make eye contact
with me
this is my girl's yard i'm in a happy
relationship stop stop
man's fully whispering to the man that's
hilarious and then it's hilarious as
soon as that's done yo
oh sick come in who's this rachel yeah
rachel
all right rachel nice to meet you this
is my girlfriend's house
future wife come on in enjoy yourself
i'm gonna be busy so don't talk to me
tonight make friends
dilly dally do you think i'm going to be
with my wife i'll catch you in a bit
i'm not jumping on anyone
[ __ ] hell but yeah don't you wrong i
can see the excitement like what the
[ __ ] are you doing here
gast but the fact that like a little
trigger in her brain didn't say
even when she hugged man nothing told
her don't wrap your legs round donny
kiss him nothing nothing came to her
head big man this is my this is your
boyfriend's yard you know
that's disrespectful yeah disrespectful
i don't know what she was thinking
that's disrespectful i don't know what
she was thinking of course she was going
to get piped that night of course
as soon as if that happened to me i
already know i'm [ __ ] like we said
before i know i'm smashing
i'll be thinking about all night that's
all i'm thinking about all night
yeah it's mad just mad um but yeah man
um you are the [ __ ] but who gives a
[ __ ] and you're not at the same time as
well so it's one of them once you enjoy
that
enjoy that well he did enjoy it yeah he
did anyway um
rap yeah man make sure you like comment
subscribe enjoy